es ist das paradies da und ich freue
mich jeden tag auf das was ich mache und
danken oft bin ich froh muslimen so im
büro schafft
sie nennen ihn busbranche großvater der
schwemme regel vater laos wurde hier in
sansibar zum meeres gärtner
zusammen mit seiner frau conny sacchi
und mohammed ocala einem lokalen partner
hat der schwarm farmen aufgebaut die den
frauen hier ein faires einkommen
garantieren sollen
wird es gelingen mit den schwämmen eine
alternative zum raubbau im meer zu
entwickeln davon handelt dieser film das
gesteckte energie 3
das macht das schwimmen das ist das
erste was seine angehende schwamm
farmerin lernen muss schwan farming ist
jedoch neuland für alle schön als auch
verloren hast du das immer das so sehr
romantischen film aber das haben wird
werde ich mir nicht erträumt die frauen
alleinerziehende aus dem dorf lernen von
conny das handwerk wenn sie sich sicher
genug fühlen können sie eine eigene farm
übernehmen und selbständig schwämme
produzieren
die schwämme müssen geputzt und
regelmäßig geschnitten werden damit sie
zu einem badeschwamm mit ansprechender
form heranwachsen massy und casey die
ersten spann farmerin demnächst
selbständig werden
die arbeit gefällt mir und ich hoffe
dass mein leben nur besser wird ein
schwamm wird geerntet sobald er groß
genug ist
die erste frau in chamonix die ein boot
steuern
ocala freut sich mit katy er neuer
erfahrungen macht kriegel und conny so
mein eindruck bringen zweifellos
frischen wind nach sambia
das dorf mit etwa 8000 einwohnern liegt
an der ostküste des hansi bars ein haus
am meer ist ein verwirklichte traum
da haben sich zwei gefunden denke ich
zwei globetrotter zwei lebende auf der
suche nach einem sinnvollen gemeinsamen
projekt krieges tochter ist erwachsen
nun gehen die kinder des dorfes hier ein
und aus für mich ein zeichen dass das
paar im dorf integriert ist von isa khel
war 1999 erstmals in sansibar
mit der zeit wurde aus der
feriendestinationen ein wohnsitz noch
arbeitet sie sechs monate im jahr beim
film als maskenbildnerin doch regel ist
das ganze jahr hier
seit 2008 ist er hauptberuflich meeres
gärtner sansibar oder der letzte grund
denke ich was ist der grund für sansibar
spaß macht lizenz so herzlich und vor
allem hand ihnen modelle zeigen sie
hatte so eine schlechte schulbildung und
st pauli was für möglichkeiten sie
rundum hand und mit denen es aufbauen wo
sie merkt habe ich so viel
bewerkstelligen dass sie sich doch ganz
schön und das ist nicht nur für sie
sondern für euch das ist einfach
spannend extrem ihr damaliger mini
fortum wird nie erfüllen
heute gehen die meeres gärtner setzlinge
für eine neue form holen
ob regel vater lauf sich hin sansibar so
bedingungslos engagiert weil er im
notfall eine wohlhabende familie im
hintergrund hätte oder kann einem
schweizer rund um sozial abgesichert
sowieso nichts passieren wie er findet
ich erlebe ihn als abenteurer und als
jemanden der sich mit all seiner
schaffenskraft dafür einsetzt die dinge
zum besseren zu verändern mit ocala hat
regel einen gleichgesinnten lokalen
partner einen öko aktivisten aus sambia
nie gefunden
in dieser bucht wächst der schwarm den
sie heute kultivieren etwa 120 arten
haben sie über die jahre ausprobiert
am anfang haben sie tauchend nach
schwimmen gesucht ohne eine geeignete
art zu finden
das war schon rührend lied vom
schwimmverband und eine sonderrolle die
fristen ablaufen und eben gesamte
material zu machen und einen schwamm
kunden gut die gute produkte qualität
und teilte dann vom fuß schnarchend
besucher ziemlich nur dann eine kunde
ganz praktisch abgeschnitten haben als
fertiges produkt rasch wieder mehr
übernehmen nur ein teil
und dann tut sich das wiederholen und
wächst einfach wie die natur die
anforderungen an den schwamm er soll
möglichst schnell wachsen er soll sich
beim baden angenehm anfühlen schön
aussehen und er solle robust sein
dieser mehr viele graue auf den ersten
blick unscheinbare schwamm machte das
rennen
schwämme zählen zu den tieren mit etwa
10.000 verschiedenen arten
sie gelten als apotheken des meeres weil
sie viel eher für die medizin
interessante stoffe produzieren für die
meeres gärtner ein potenzial das sie
vielleicht in zukunft nutzen wollen
spaness in lebendige mehrere sorgen dass
man nun ist es zu hans deshalb müssen
wir schnell machen damit sie gesund und
sicher ankommen
die betonklötze die neue schwamm
fahnenmeer verankern haben regeln und
ein paar männer des dorfes vor tagen
schon gegossen drei farmen hat marin
cultures bisher verbucht nicht so große
sind vielleicht 15 schwarz pharma
möglich damit mit einem nettogehalt
monokulturen hat das ist das problem das
man nicht dass beliebige multiplizieren
die bucht ist demnach zu klein für
eagles große pläne schwamm formen sollen
deshalb auch anderswo in sansibar
entstehen
gegründet von leuten die bei neuen
cultures ausgebildet werden
eine neue form braucht nur etwa 150
dollar an investitionen beton schnüre
und brühen
ich wundere mich dass man hier ihm mehr
einfach so eine neue form abstecken kann
den wegen der schnüre können die fische
hier nicht fischen
trotzdem waren sie einverstanden sie
seien wegen des rückgangs der fische
froh um neue ideen sagt regel aqua
farming liegt mindestens so weit weg von
ihrem werdegang wie ich sansibar von der
schweiz
conny ist maskenbildnerin kriegel war
vieles aktivist kinobetreiber
firmengründer reiseleiter im jemen und
unternehmensberater ihre inspiration in
sansibar wir zebras angebaut für die
kosmetik- und lebensmittelindustrie und
am schluss von monatlich 20 euro
[Musik]
das müsste doch
rote liegt ami wird bringen das hat aber
auf kleine sieht dass eine faszination
kann das lied dann nicht nur zügellosen
mehr holen sondern die meerespflanzen
der bis kultivieren dass eine schwamm
farm so wenig investitionen braucht gab
schließlich den ausschlag vorkenntnisse
hatten sie keine große reise gemacht
haben in der ostheimer es dann
eigentlich auf programm
alle orte für ackerkulturen slogan auf
die ganze welt
das ist stieg sie die pelle
ich finde jetzt hat einfach schönes
produkt
ob es kompliziert das ist gewiss formen
und transformer
und frau befahren schließlich trafen sie
jemanden der sie auf schwämme und
korallen brachte wir sind kamerun
biologe
das braucht gar nicht es braucht
weiteres buch business entwickelst bucht
liegt wo das neue norton community ob
diese neue soft power & tax einkommen
das problem hat dann den krimi
geschrieben nur das mail und so die
amerikanische art auf das meer ein
großer abenteuerspielplatz ok hat uns
eingeladen
die frischgebackene schwamm farmerin ist
jetzt selbstständige unternehmerin
sie zeigt uns wie die schwämme gewaschen
werden sie lebt mit ihrer mutter ihrer
ältesten tochter und ihren drei jüngeren
kindern in einem winzigen zwei zimmer
haus der mann hat sie in stich gelassen
für die kinder muss sie alleine sorgen
von ihm bekomme ich gar nichts
einmal im jahr schickt er manchmal
kleider für die kinder für den feiertag
dank der schwamm verdient kay nun genug
um die familie zu ernähren
es ist ein teilzeitjob der sie etwa 16
tage im monat beschäftigt und der
verdienst ist abhängig davon wie schnell
die schwämme wachsen
jetzt kommt darauf an wie groß die
schwämme sind meistens etwa 176 dollar
pro monat nun diejenigen die geld hat
sie ist die königin des hauses der rauch
vom kochen bringt die kinder zum husten
nicht einmal dieses ärmliche haus gehört
kay bekannte haben es hier für eine
begrenzte zeit überlassen um ihr zu
helfen
zwei zimmer für sechs leute das sind
beengte verhältnisse besonders in der
regenzeit ihr großer traum ist deshalb
ein eigenes haus was sie als schwarm
farmerin sparen kann fließt in den bau
schritt für schritt geht es voran
in etwa vier jahren soll ihr haus fertig
sein
die schweizer hätten ihr aber nicht nur
materiell etwas gebracht sagt kay ich
freue mich sehr die beiden zu kennen
früher kannte ich nur leute aus dem dorf
jetzt sogar solche aus europa frauen wie
kay werden die skeptischen dorfbewohner
vom schwamm pharming überzeugen
selbst in diesem dorf wo die meisten
serien sind gehörte sie vorher zu den
ärmsten nun beneiden sie viele um ihren
guten job sie kann sich etwas leisten
sansibar statt
die hauptstadt von sansibar sie ist mit
dem auto eine stunde von pia entfernt
das historische zentrum stone town ist
unesco-weltkulturerbe touristenzentrum
hierhin bringen die schwarmer ihre
schwämme
[Musik]
regel und conny gehen hier aber auch
regelmäßig auf den markt um einzukaufen
wir begleiten die meeres gärtner in den
souvenir shop wo die schwemme an
touristen aus europa und amerika
verkauft werden
je nach größe kostet der schwamm 20 bis
30 dollar
der preis soll den schwamm fahrerinnen
ein einkommen sichern das zum leben
reicht die marge für den ladenbesitzer
beträgt ein drittel
die schwämme decken nur einen winzigen
bruchteil der gesamten kosten von marin
cultures der verein finanziert sich
hauptsächlich über spenden
auf der heimfahrt grüble ich darüber
nach dass mit diesem enormen aufwand die
schwämme ebensogut vergoldet werden
könnten
regel und conny haben jahrelang
ehrenamtlich gearbeitet neue zahlt sich
regel einen lohn von 1700 franken aber
den meeres gärtnern geht es um viel mehr
als nur die schwämme worum es geht zeigt
sich in der lagune von jandia nie jeden
tag sind hier hunderte dorfbewohner
daran irgendetwas für den kochtopf zu
erjagen für touristen ein malerisches
bild für die fische ist dies weniger
schön denn in der not essen die menschen
alles die lagune gibt immer weniger her
und die menschen werden immer
zahlreicher
heute gibt es eine kleine sensation
diese fische kommen mit einem
unglaublichen fang nach hause so einen
fall gibt champions lagune längst nicht
mehr her
des rätsels lösung die fischer haben an
ihrem traditionellen dau kein segel
sondern einen großen motor
damit haben sie sich aufs offene meer
gewagt und reiche beute gemacht haben
als ein mal im monat
so träumen viele fischer von einem motor
hätte man das bild dafür dann könnte man
draußen im offenen meer fischen mit den
traditionellen boten ist dies
lebensgefährlich mit einem motor hätte
man jeden tag eine solch reiche beute
dann wären alle probleme mit der
überfischung der lagune gelöst so denken
viele hier
gegen dieses denken kämpft regel
vaterlos zweifellos könnte er mit den
spenden des vereins auch motoren für die
fischer kaufen
doch das würde in seinen augen das
problem der überfischung nur verlagern
deswegen entwickelt er neue ideen diesen
metalltisch hat er für sein neues
projekt geschweißt eine korallen farm
seit einem jahr ist er mit ocala daran
einen putsch druck aufzubauen
noch in diesem jahr sollen die ersten
korallen aus der zucht exportiert werden
der chor alle produkte sind die
momentane entwicklung und dann sind nach
der produktion nicht rein aus den
rohrstock könne sie und dann ist das
coral forming nachhaltig und bringt nur
geld das mit dem boom des aquarium
handelns werden immer mehr korallen
gewildert und für viel geld verkauft mit
der zucht nimmt der druck auf die
wildbestände ab deswegen wird marin
cultures vom zoo basel mit 10000 franken
jährlich unterstützt eine große
anerkennung für die arbeit der meeres
gärtner die korallen können geschnitten
und so vermehrt werden weiche korallen
werden aufgespießt part korallen auf
einem sogenannten substrat angelangt von
den schwämmen zu den korallen und weiter
je länger die meeres gärtner sich mit
dem mehr beschäftigen
umso umfangreicher werden ihre
aktivitäten
dazu gehören diese rief bälle zum schutz
der fische zusammen mit einheimischen
fischern haben sie diese kugeln gegossen
hier können sich fischer verstecken und
hierzu haben die fischer miteinander
vereinbart soll nicht gefischt werden
glauben sie dass man das denken der
fischer ändern kann so dass sie den
nutzen 1 auf jeden fall
doch es gibt zwei lager die einen
verstehen was er tun
sie sehen dass wir ernsthafte probleme
haben und der umwelt sorge tragen müssen
die anderen sind also die einen sehen
ist die anderen nicht
ich stelle fest dass riegels ambitionen
sich keineswegs auf die bucht von
fabiani beschränken
ministerium nicht viel bekannt darum
haben wir dank dass miro sie erwähnen es
kampagne bewusstseinskampagne eigentlich
nicht nur fischer beschränken sondern
oft regierung lügt und den sportraum
natürlich schulklasse dass die kommende
generationen auch zusammenhang von mehr
bestand und wüsste wie sicher schützen
und wir sind bewusst fische damit
mädchen
der mann hat eine mission und ich
zweifele nicht daran dass er ganz
ansehbar umkrempeln wird falls man ihn
machen lässt und ich bewundere die
energie von regel und conny jeden tag
diesen großen persönlichen einsatz zu
leisten ohne zu wissen ob er sich
langfristig lohnen wird
und ich muss sagen nicht leeren da eine
ganz persönliche und der anderen kultur
haben
das ist das was mir daran japan geht die
deine pro jahr
das macht und es gibt gesetzliche bis
größe
[Musik]
[Applaus]